سيطر شهلا على المركز الأول ، وكان موسمه الأول
في ميرسيسايد حيث سجل أكثر من 40
هدفًا وقدم تمريرات لا حصر لها ،
فهو أفضل لاعب أفريقي حالي لهذا
العام وفاز بجائزة
أفضل لاعب في الدوري الإنجليزي الممتاز
ثلاث مرات ، وهو ببساطة
أحد أهم خصائص كرة القدم على الإطلاق.
كوكب ماذا عن يورجن كلوب
والجهاز الفني هنا ، ما مدى
الفارق الذي أحدثوه في الطريقة
التي تلعب بها والتحسن في
تسجيل أهدافك هو مدرب
رائع أيضًا رجل رائع ، لقد جعلني كثيرًا
لتحسين نفسي وأنا أيضًا
أثق  للعب ما أريده ، لدينا
علاقة جيدة بالمكان الذي نرى فيه بلداننا ،
كما تعلمون ، إنها
السنة الأولى وكل شيء يسير على ما يرام ، لذا
ليس ما يمكنني قوله الآن ولكني
سعيد جدًا هنا وسعداء جدًا
بالجماهير  كل شيء على ما يرام ، لذا ما هو
شعورك في المرة الأولى التي خرجت فيها
إلى هذه الحفرة التي لعبت فيها لأول مرة
هنا كان أمرًا لا يصدق ، أشعر أنني
لم ألعب من قبل ولكن عندما تكون كل مباراة
هنا  جميل جدًا أن المجال الخاص بي رائع جدًا ،
هل تشعر بتاريخ هذا
النادي لأن هذا ليس مجرد نادٍ لكرة
القدم ، هذه هي المدينة ، نعم
أشعر بالاختلاف حتى داخل
غرفة الملابس التي تعرفها عندما تمشي في
النفق في كل مكان ، إنها رائعة
تبدو الدراسة حمراء كل شيء على ما
يرام